axe ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines continue
d'évoluer et se développe au taux de
grands projets d'aménagement qui
changeront très certainement le
quotidien des saint quentinois dans les
années à venir état des lieux vous me
suivez c'est par là elle est venue
cinquante ans neeve il n'a cessé
d'évoluer elle continue aujourd'hui à le
faire et parmi les grands projets à
venir il ya bien sûr l'agrandissement du
périmètre de la communauté
d'agglomération avec ce nom parce que
ceux des lois aujourd'hui qui nous
impose d'être dans une intercommunalité
de plus de deux cent mille habitants
saint-quentin aujourd'hui ses 148
minutes en coup de vent à voir un
nouveau périmètre pour nous permettre de
pouvoir atteindre cet objectif la salir
d'être en conformité avec la loi alors
ensuite il ya plusieurs possibilités
sauf qu'aujourd'hui le préfet de région
a sorti le schéma régional
et là haut niveau montré très surpris
puisque on veut nous intégrer dans une
intercommunalité de huit cent mille
habitants qui est tout simplement la
plus grande internet et de france après
quelques métropoles paris mais de
province dont bien sûr des contres nous
sommes contre ce périmètre là et là je
pense que je peux le dire à l'unanimité
premièrement un problème de gouvernance
57 communes qui composeraient ce nouveau
périmètre nouveau périmètre qui pourra
doit bien compris d'une re sud ou de
l'est à l'ouest représente la distance
entre orly et roissy et puis surtout on
veut marier des intercommunalités
existantes déjà mais qui n'ont pas la
même histoire et surtout qu'ils n'ont
pas le même niveau d'intégration
intercommunale 50 ans
nous sommes humains issus de la ville
nouvelle donc nous connaissons interne
alité depuis plus de 40 ans et notre
intégration un terminal est de 50 % et
50 % des compétences sont exercées par
l'intercommunalité grâce à grands pas
notre grande voisine un taux d'anomalie
t il se situe autour de 15 % pour qu'on
voit bien que ce sera très compliqué
dans la gouvernance et surtout aussi
dans l'application administrative des
choses puisque on n'est pas nouveau mais
le niveau est donc on va perdre beaucoup
de temps des années avant de pouvoir
retrouver une façon de travailler les
élus d évident
sont unanimes contre ce périmètre l'a
ensuite bien le préfet de région a saisi
toutes les communes et toutes les
intercommunalités qui devront se
prononcer dans un délai de trois mois
at-on d'ici la fin de l'année toutes les
communes qui sont concernés par ce
périmètre devront donner leur avis ainsi
bien sûr que la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
ensuite à bien le préfet de région va à
nouveau réunir cette commission
régionale au mois de février et l'a donc
y aura deux possibilités
soit de déposer des amendements pour
faire évoluer ce périmètre de la part
des élus soit le préfet pourrait
lui-même aussi apporté quelques
modifications
après il ya d'autres possibilités
la première possibilité et qui est pour
moi la plus plausible c'est tout
simplement de reconstituer ce qu'on
appelle le grand saint quentin sur les
bases de l'ancienne ville nouvelle c'est
à dire de pouvoir intégrer dans le
territoire de celle de saint quentin la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien composé de plaisir les clés et
villepreux plus les villes de maurepas
et de quoi hier ce qui nous paraît le
plus logique possible cela nous
permettrait d'être au delà bien sûr des
chiffres imposée par la loi une affaire
que nous suivons de près bien entendu en
attendant 50 ans ni vie continue de se
développer autour de grands projets qui
vont encore renforcer son poids il ya
des projets comme entrée de quartier sur
villa roi c'est un quartier qui est déjà
largement construit dans lequel il ya
des projets complémentaires
c'est un peu la même chose sur la clé de
saint pierre est en cours là on trouve
aussi des logements complément de ce qui
existe déjà pour conforter l'offre de
logements sur ce secteur est important
de pouvoir continuer à françois des
logements pour les habitants qui vit sur
place et puis pour des salariés
d'entreprises qui continuent d'arriver
sur ce territoire c'est aussi le cas de
développement l'humilier du wing raw ou
là on s'adresse davantage aux étudiants
ou jeunes chercheurs aux jeunes actifs
donc avec des chambres étudiantes de
l'hôtellerie aussi puisque les
entreprises sont à cette demande aux
d'avoir des hôtels un peu dernière
génération on a un dispositif autorisé
sur saint quentin qui vieillit c'est un
petit peu
c'est le cas d'autres quartiers comme
l'aérostat qui est plus un quartier de
liaison
au sein de l'atlantide au fond ne s'agit
de rien
urbanisme de la peine 9 mai par
l'intermédiaire de ce quartier de relier
des rues de voirie qui étaient des gens
qui peut on à pas sans coût de 5 donc de
redonner
un aménagement d'ensemble à un quartier
de conforter 6,9 des logements
diversifiés qui l'a se positionne donc
sur l'accession puisque c'est un
quartier beaucoup de la cathine
l'airé aucun quartier sur l ankou on a
c'est aussi une quartier de liaison
un petit peu plus déconnectés mais qui
était un quartier de maisons aussi en
logements principalement c'est aussi une
hausse de l'offre de logement mais créer
de nouveaux quartiers c'est aussi
anticiper et travailler à long terme une
telle aberration au travail sur des
projets pour pour demain puisque c'est
des projets qui se monte il faut mettre
en place le droit des sols mettre en
place la programmation pour pouvoir
démarrer dans dc d'ici quelques années
un an
trois ans des opérations avec des
promoteurs qui se construiront des
opérations qui elle-même mettront un ou
deux ans à se construire donc une
opération d'aménagement ça se travaille
sur la durée
mais les grands projets de la bio c'est
aussi la préparation et l'accueil de
grands événements sportifs tels que la
ryder cup du third hussenot du sky à
hénon g love me c'est du golfe avec le
golf un événement planétaire honnêtement
je pense pas parce que c'est pas un
sport qui m'intéresse moi non je pense
pas que ce soit en sport qui intéresse
les gens de mon âge en fait à faux la
ryder cup est un des événements sportifs
les plus suivis dans le monde alors
qu'est ce qu'on dit je trouve que ça
peut que renforcer l'image de la ville
et puis que ça peut lui que lui offrira
un point de vue international sur la vie
donc je trouve que c'est une bonne
initiative d'accueillir c'est dans la
ville à ce projet fantastique c'est un
émolument planétaire que nous aurons la
chance d'organiser en 2018 et comme
chacun sait marie d'heure pop et la
confrontation
d'equipe de golf européenne avec les
états unis
et
cette compétition accueille des
visiteurs du monde entier qui vont bien
évidemment alimenté tout le secteur
hôtelier et le commerce le calme c'est
également l'occasion pour un grand
nombre de chefs d'entreprises de
assister à cette compétition est de
créer des liens avec nos services donc
du développement économique est
incontestablement des possibilités
ouvertes de
d'implantation peut-être grande
manifestation
qui comme la coupe du monde de football
passionne passionne tout le monde
golfique et avec un grand nombre de
visiteurs puisque on attend plus de cent
mille visiteurs pendant la période où
sera se déroulera cette compétition au
golf national de guyancourt en attendant
les amateurs de sport pourront profiter
des championnats du monde de piste us
ses clips qui se dérouleront à 50 ans ni
vis du 18 au 22 février prochain nous
avons la chance d'avoir été retenu comme
organisateur des championnats du monde
pci sur piste c'est un événement qui va
permettre à notre vélodrome d'acquérir
ses lettres de noblesse pour avoir une
renommée mondiale au travers de cette
magnifique compétition là aussi nous
attendons un grand nombre de visiteurs
mais les grands projets de sports et de
loisirs se sont aussi de grands projets
d'aménagement comme celui de la colline
des langues ça fait partie du dispositif
donc sports loisirs
entre le vélodrome la base de loisirs et
bien évidemment le golf national
maintenant nous avons le dernier maillon
qui est celui de d'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt sur cette colline ya
un projet ambitieux qui consiste en
l'installation d'une piste de ski est
parfois décrié mais qui est un
équipement là aussi d'importants ce
parce qu'il va permettre donc à
saint-quentin d'être connue là encore de
façon
je dirais internationale qui va générer
des des emplois on attend je dirais près
de la création de 200 emplois et
évidemment des activités qui seront
organisées au pied de cette colline et
qui permettront d'avoir un lieu de vie
qui n'existe pas à l'heure actuelle et
qui sera ouvert à tous les saint
quentinois
simultanément nous entendons aménagé
tout le reste est de la colline en parc
floral est ouvert au public
et voici pour d'autres dossiers
consacrés donc aux grands projets
d'aménagement de saint quentin en
yvelines et maintenant on retrouve on
retrouve nos actus du mois eh oui
et on débute avec un succès ouvert en
novembre 2004 l'ugc ciné-cité skywest
est aujourd'hui l'un des cinémas les
plus fréquentés de france avec 1,3
million d'entrées par an pour fêter ses
10 ans à tarif promotionnel et de
nombreuses animations et projections où
seront proposés du 4 au 14 novembre on
poursuit en couleurs puisque en
partenariat avec l'institut de promotion
de la santé nih ps la mutualité
française ile de france et la ville de
trappes en yvelines organise octobre
rose le 17 octobre prochain au programme
de cette journée de promotion du
dépistage du cancer du sein des rendez
vous avec les habitants des stands de
sensibilisation des animations marché
une expo mairie du travail réalisé par
les femmes relais et la projection du
film attrape ta santé au grenier à sel
et on termine avec un zoom sur la
guyancourt toise maria gaffney qui avec
l'aide de la maison de l'entreprise qui
l'a soutenu lui a accordé un prêt
d'honneur a pu lancer ce n'est au clic
au printemps dernier à huy en cours
la crêperie du village développe depuis
l'art de réinventer la crêpe de façon
originale pour en faire des lasagnes ou
encore des crocs
qui
et voici donc pour les actus du mois
quand un autre dossier vous pouvez le
retrouver dans le petit quentin du mois
d'octobre un magazine dans lequel vous
retrouverez également pleins d'articles
intéressants comme celui qui est
consacré par exemple à la nouvelle
saison jeune public et cet autre qui est
consacrée à la toute nouvelle exposition
de port royal des champs qui vous
prépare un mini beauvoir 6,6 à bientôt